hey youtubers is Charlie so HBO did the
wonderful thing of dropping a whole
bunch of teaser images for Game of
Thrones season 6 so let's do a breakdown
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far and
there is a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I guess let's do this in a
slideshow format the pictures that they
posted we're out of order so I'm just
gonna do these as they appear starting
with the biggest one first the biggest
WTF bran and the three-eyed Raven
standing in broad daylight it's kind of
hard to tell where they are it looks
like there's somewhere in the north they
might be in Winterfell this could be
happening in a vision they could
actually be standing outside based on
where they left things at the end of
season 4 on the TV show with the
three-eyed Raven you know kind of being
ingrown with the root system almost in
the end of book 5 where it seemed like
that was gonna happen to brain
eventually - I'm wondering if this is
all happening in division but look how
big bran is he's grown up so fast that's
one of the problems with using child
actors that they grow up way faster than
their characters Ramsay and Roose Bolton
gonna have a fun time trying to hold
Winterfell in the north
remember the whole reason that Roose
wanted to marry Sansa - Ramsay is so
that it would legitimize his claim in
the eyes of the rest of the north but
because Sansa is on the run now they
have to deal with that and looming on
the horizon you have an army of White
Walkers but that's not really a threat
really the biggest threat to them right
now is the rest of the north the north
that remembers so I'll be really
interested to see which houses of the
north rally behind Sansa when they find
that she's still alive and on the run in
which rally - ruses banner he would not
be Game of Thrones if everyone's
allegiances were set in stone there's
always gonna be houses flipping sides
Balon Greyjoy very much alive I'll be
really interested to see if he stays
that way through season six there's the
idea that we might get at Kingsmoot
because we have euron greyjoy coming we
also have Yara that's coming back - I
know her name is Asha in the books but
they they changed it for the show
because of OSHA they didn't want people
who did not read the books to be
confused but she's still got her armor
on I'll be really interested to see how
they get involved with the northern part
line two as much as they're changing
things though they are circling back
around to get book four and five stuff
that they skipped over during season
five
especially during Jaime's storyline
speaking of which Myrcella confirmed
dead r.i.p just another princess dead
and buried right after the season ended
the actress who plays her made a funny
comment about Game of Thrones problems
in the actors that used to play Marcela
and was recast was like sister I totally
understand how you feel so you have two
different Marcela's that got killed off
the show sympathizing with each other
like being a princess getting killed
just comes with the territory although
to be fair the original Marcela didn't
get killed off but she was effectively
killed off when she was recast how many
times have we been in the great Sept
because of a funeral in the last couple
of seasons there was Jon Arryn in season
one
Joffrey in season four then Tywin in
season five now we have Myrcella just
the latest in a line of funerals and
dead Lannisters I'm really interested to
see how Jaime and Cersei processed this
they were slowly drifting apart I think
Brienne was really a positive influence
on Jaime in the books and on the show
their relationship in the books is a
little bit different than it is in the
show they brought TV show Jaime and
Brienne much closer than book Jaime and
Brienne were logically what I'm
expecting from Jaime and Cersei though
is that this will break them
psychologically whether or not they show
it outwardly I mean they'll probably
lash out they might end up having
twincest again and I feel like their
characters on the TV show are moving in
a book direction that is they're slowly
drifting apart
Jaime won't be quite as obsessed with
Cersei as he was in the past
speaking of obsessed high Sparrow
obsessed with inequality in the Seven
Kingdoms there was that teaser where he
talked about banding together
overthrowing the powerful so I'm just
expecting the faith militant to be a
really big thing in season six or at
least the movement to start sweeping
through the Seven Kingdoms most of
what's been going on with the faith has
been localized to King's Landing in
season five I'm expecting that that will
start to spread Brienne looking none the
worse for wear maybe somewhere in the
north he doesn't look quite as cold in
the north as in the Sansa pictures so
she might be a little further south
Sansa though some awesome Sansa pictures
what I'm wondering from the two of them
is do they head towards
eastwatch-by-the-sea up near the wall to
the head to Castle black
or do they head to the West closer to
where Theon is from the Iron Islands do
they seek help from his family the thing
about that area though is I don't think
it would be snowing nearly this much so
I think they are much closer to the wall
logically you think that Sansa would be
the brains of this operation she's the
only one that's thinking clearly and she
would probably think hey my brother is
at the wall maybe I'll go there but they
could take her in a number of different
directions she might even try to head to
one of the houses that she knows is
loyal to the Starks like say to the last
hearth
warehouse numbers seat is there's also a
rumor that that's where Rickon is going
to be to Rickon and osha because they
might be showing up too even though it's
not necessarily that way in the books
I'm expecting the books in the show to
deviate a little bit as to where Rickon
resurfaces but Sansa here it just looks
absolutely done taking people
I was really hoping that she get to this
point after season four like that was
with that look with Littlefinger was at
the end of season four wearing that
black dress
turns out didn't really go down that way
they wanted to rake her over the coals
over the Ramsay calls for a little while
so I guess you could say what they might
be doing is taking the Lady Stoneheart
character and splitting that
characterization giving Sansa and say
like the Jon Snow character aspects of
that personality in that plotline for
that matter just the idea that the North
remembers and now everyone is effed if
you haven't read the books the Lady
Stoneheart character is just a character
that comes back in exacts revenge but
she's kind of this force of nature in
that if you step in her path even if
you're not a bad person
you will still totally be effed just not
you know not completely thinking clearly
just out for some good old-fashioned
revenge just looking at these pictures
doesn't really tell us the whole story
but it does look like revenge is on her
mind but mostly when the season picks up
they're still gonna be on the run so
they have to find where they're going
first before people can rally behind
Sansa and she can form a plan like okay
now we need to get rid of the Bolton's
how do we do that
and we have Samwell Gilly and Gilley's
baby here on their way to Old Town I'm
really interested to see how much of Old
Town we get to see because it seems like
they cast some pretty significant actors
for his family but his family does not
live in Old Town so they'd have to
travel all the way to horn Hill to see
that so maybe he'll go to horn Hill
first then go to Old Town or maybe we'll
bounce back and forth between those two
I can't wait to see Highgarden - I'm
hoping we get to see Highgarden if we're
already gonna be in that part of
Westeros moving to the east now Daenerys
looking terrible still with the Dothraki
I love the Dothraki teaser you are queen
of nothing
the Dothraki just absolutely do not care
about her at all so it's gonna be really
fun to see how she deals with that
situation because in the last couple of
seasons every time she rolls up she has
an army at her back she has bigger
dragons that are really fearsome but now
she doesn't have that it seems like
drogon is gonna be out of commission for
just a little while but he'll definitely
be back Tyrion miss and I grey worm
Varys looks like they have to deal with
marine
I'll be really interested to see what
they do about the harpies because even
though drogon rolled in like a boss and
a snacks pit at the end of last season
he didn't eat all the harpies or the
people behind them so all these people
that Daenerys left behind are gonna have
to deal with internal threats and marine
like the harpies and external threats
too just because she liberated the
people doesn't mean the people like the
wise masters won't just rush right back
in the minute she leaves so I'm
expecting some old foes from slavers Bay
to come back and try to haunt marine but
because Daenerys isn't there her new
small Council for whatever you want to
call it is gonna have to deal with it
themselves
poor arya blind cat of the canals in the
books uses the name mercy so i'll be
real interested to see how many episodes
she goes as this mercy character seeking
mercy giving mercy the mercy of death I
know it seems like she's living on the
streets in this picture but really this
is just her crucible this blindness is
her crucible to survive and they're
actually crediting this is a Marjory
picture so now we know that Margaery is
still at the mercy of the faith still in
the black cells but aside from the shame
none we really don't know what's going
on with the trial of the faith because
they only tease that at the end the last
season just because everyone confess
Margaery Loras and Cersei doesn't mean
that they're off scot-free so let me
know in the comments of all these
teasers which is your favorite what's
your favorite picture from season 6 and
I know everyone's wondering when the
trailers gonna drop I was kind of hoping
that they'd drop it in the last week
which was why I was holding out for a
new video that hasn't happened but they
might drop one this Sunday with the
premiere of vinyl they have a new series
that's premiering this weekend so
whatever ends up happening I'll totally
do a video for it no worries there
actually have been quite a few teasers
so far so white guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for all
my Game of Thrones Season 6 videos and
you can click here for the big Batman V
Superman trail that I just posted thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight